séparatisme oui je pense qu'il ya un
séparatisme monsieur thaddée nick nous
avons plusieurs cas de d'infraction à la
laïcité qui remonte au ministère de
l'éducation nationale nous avons
plusieurs cas d'école qui endoctrinent
des enfants notamment le centre des
lumières par exemple qu'il a été fermé
aller à st à saint denis il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça
nous avons des problèmes de livres qui
sont vendus alors qu'ils sont interdits
par exemple comment apprendre le tao
shield aux enfants sont interdits on a
encore des demandeurs qui achètent ça
pour enseigner quoi aux mineurs nous
avons un problème de séparatisme quand
on exige de jeunes petites filles qui
vont à l'école de portée des petits
fiable pour aller dans des caves de
l'école hors contrat
non ce n'est pas le nombre qui compte
c'est la protection de tous voilà et
agité l'islamophobie et qui n'est autre
que un prétexte pour ne pas s'attaquer à
tout cela ne doit pas fonctionner et je
pense que les pouvoirs publics ne
doivent pas céder là dessus ensuite
dernière chose ma définition de la
laïcité j'ai été étonné d'entendre que
je la des foyers jamais je n'ai prétendu
l'aide la dévoyer j'ai juste revendiquer
l'égalité en droits entre les non
croyants et les croyants et c'est à dire
on les chrétiens ou peu importe le droit
de convertir m prosélyte de critiquer
les religions et des convertir
rappelez moi enfin corrigez moi si j'ai
tort autre chose neutralité de l'état
oui séparation des églises et de l'état
oui mais liberté de conscience de
cliquer ans et la neutralité la laïcité
ça n'a aucun sens je ne comprends pas
comment on peut m'accuser de dévoyer la
laïcité
[Musique]